good evening members resumption of the
meeting of the 30th uh of March
um I'll just remind you about a
declaration of interests if you need to
make one any members that are here that
feel they might need to
but please do so at any appropriate
appropriate time uh we are live to
finish the minutes of the Council of the
22nd we had an issue this afternoon
um but I think Miss bird has resolved it
[Applause]
could you remind there are members here
this evening that weren't here this
afternoon so could you remind members
um what the issue was and what the res
and what the resolution is
out of course China and Council Philippa
an eraser query in relation to the
minutes the 22nd of February in
particular a gender white of Aid which
was the budget and need to internal
Financial strategy he queried a
particular paragraph into the report in
relation to a resolution that wasn't
clear and we've checked it and in fact
that
it doesn't relate to that many it was an
error on my behalf of neurologist thank
you Miss bird so members to complete
these morning at this afternoon's
approval of the council minutes do you
now agree the council
thank you
um we now go to a gender item 15
exclusion of the public and press
um
I proposed to resolve that under Section
180 for the Local Government Act 1972
the public be excluded from the meeting
for the following items of business on
the grounds that they may involve the
likely disclosure of exempt information
as defined in paragraph three of part
one of schedule 12a to the ACT and that
this satisfies the public interest test
and that's in relation to a tender item
16 17 18 19 and 20.
can I have a second
yes thank you members agree agree all
right
um thank you
uh will you let me know when we're off
stream